all right had a Las Vegas veteran is
right on the edge of living on the
street he blames it on his caregiver who
he says allegedly stole thousands of
dollars from him but as Ryan Matthey
shows us he doesn't want to prosecute
and his close friend is struggling to
save him from homelessness
for 13 years Richard Romano says he's
lived comfortably in this apartment
complex this is after serving in the
Navy and losing both of his legs now
he's evicted saying he could not pay
rent because thousands were stolen from
him but responding to all that lost
money is now a conflict
60. okay the 81 year old struggles to
talk about his military past I ended up
getting a a fungus on the bottom of my
foot
and it turned it into gangrene now he's
struggling to make ends meet I'm going
over the transactions as I did you do
that one no did you do that one no
Richard Stevens is known romano and his
caregiver for years a caregiver the
veteran hired not knowing he was not
licensed they accused this caregiver of
stealing thousands in monthly Social
Security benefits the only other person
they say that had access to his account
the caregiver ran and the veteran could
not pay rent I literally started crying
Stevens then taking it upon himself to
find Romano shelter because Prosecuting
the suspected culprit is not of Interest
so believe it or not he started out
doing really well and then he turned
into a piece
so you're trying to give them a second
chance yeah well then you become
hopeless
we're not going to move forward with
that then there's only hell I'm going to
let this man on the street and while
that friend does say some volunteers are
helping in the short term the long-term
solution remains unclear reporting from
near Decatur and Flamingo Ryan Matthey 8
News Now
so Ryan also checked with the apartment
and a manager told him that they
attempted to connect the man with Adult
Protective Services they haven't had any
luck so far and the friend says this
veteran has no family that can assume
legal guardianship